this is it
here we all are together at last to talk
about optimism
if this isn't nice i don't know what is
here's the problem it's 20 2021.
we are living through a global plague
one that revealed our worst instincts at
the worst times
we are so divided that public health has
become a power struggle
we pioneered a vaccine a moon landing
level innovation and then kept it among
wealthy countries while poor ones
suffered
against this backdrop isn't talking
about optimism like discussing pagers or
horse-drawn carriages
isn't optimism obsolete backwards and
naive
given all we've been through
shouldn't it be replaced with a more
up-to-date cognitive technology
well lots of people have replaced it
with cynicism the notion that humanity
is greedy selfish and dishonest
in 1972 45 of americans thought that
most people can be trusted by 2018 that
had dropped to about 30 percent
we are living through a cynicism
epidemic
i should know
last year it infected me and i'm
supposed to be immune
i'm a psychologist and neuroscientist
and my whole career i've studied the
sunny side of human nature
my lab and i have found that giving away
money activates similar parts of your
brain as eating chocolate
and that helping other people through
their stress calms our own
our punchline is clear
there is good in us and it does good for
us
now people love hearing this but in 2020
i started to hate saying it i was
building hope in others while losing my
own i was evangelizing for human
kindness all day and then doom scrolling
at night
i was peddling something that i would
never want to buy anymore
i felt like a fraud
or at best maybe a fax machine salesman
but here's the thing
you might think that cynicism is a
system upgrade that allows us to see who
we really are
it's not
it traps us in a version of the world we
don't want to live in and when we don't
have to
one of my favorite studies of all time
occurred in southeastern brazil
two fishing villages there are separated
by just 30 miles
one sits by the ocean where fishing
requires large boats and heavy equipment
to make a living there fishermen must
work together
the other sits by a lake where fishermen
strike out alone on small boats and
compete with one another
years ago researchers tested how people
in each of these villages responded to a
set of social experiments
ocean fishermen trusted strangers and
cooperated with their neighbors
lake fishermen competed and mistrusted
instead
but here's the crazy part these folks
didn't start out any different from each
other
but the longer fishermen worked on the
lake the more they competed
the longer they worked on the ocean the
less they did
some families schools and companies are
like ocean villages
people trust because they know others
will earn it
some are like lake towns people look out
for themselves because no one else will
our social worlds shape us like clay
into hopeful or cynical versions of
ourselves and right now many of us are
living in a lake town of historic
proportion
inequality has sword injustice is all
around self-interest might as well be
pumped into the water supply
these forces raise cynicism
and so do times of disaster
after the last 18 months there's a real
chance we could tip into a sort of
cynical permafrost
now
i'm going to guess that there might be
some proud cynics in the audience today
and you might be thinking good
more people should turn to the dark side
optimism might feel nice so would
calling tiramisu a health food but we
don't get to go around believing
whatever we like
george bernard shaw tells us that the
power of accurate observation is
commonly called cynicism by those who
haven't got it
107 years later the cartoon philosopher
lisa simpson taught us that as
intelligence goes up happiness goes down
maybe hope does too
maybe cynicism is the price of being
right
most people think so
70 percent think cynics are smarter than
non-cynics 85 think they would make
better lie detectors
most people are wrong
it turns out that cynics tend to perform
less well than non-cynics on cognitive
tests they earn less money and they lose
more often in negotiations
they're not even good at spotting bad
guys
in one study researchers conducted mock
job interviews asking half the
candidates to lie and have to tell the
truth
cynics and non-cynics watched videos of
these interviews and guessed who is
lying
and cynics did way worse
more generally they assume liars are
everywhere so can't pick real ones out
of the crowd
so
cynicism might not be as smart as you
think it is but it's still powerful
because our stories about each other
become self-fulfilling
cynics are more likely to refuse
intimacy and cooperation they hurt
others to avoid being hurt
they tend to spy on their colleagues and
suspect their friends and other people
unsurprisingly react badly
sometimes acting selfishly in response
in other words by mistreating others
cynics create the exact conditions they
fear
they tell a story full of villains and
end up living in it
i call this the cynicism trap and my lab
explores ways that people fall into it
in one study we ask people how happiness
works
some thought that it's a zero-sum game
meaning that as one person's happiness
goes up another person's must go down
now they're wrong it turns out that when
we act generously towards others that
tends to increase our happiness
but cynics acted on their illusion
when given chances to help strangers
they were less likely to do so
they ended up less happy as well
by hoarding well-being they lost out on
one of its key ingredients
other people
in other work we asked republicans and
democrats what it would mean to
empathize with the other side
some people saw politics as a war and
thought empathy would be as useful as
bringing cotton candy to a gun fight
these folks didn't want to cooperate
with the other side or even to know them
at all
in one study we measured college
students cynicism about empathy and
asked about the friends they made on
campus
here each dot is a person coded blue to
red based on ideology and each line is a
friendship
now this was a pretty liberal campus but
nonetheless non-cynics managed to find
ideologically diverse friends cynics
stuck to their own kind
now that's of course their right
but most of us wish our country was less
divided and empathy is critical to
moving us towards that goal
by giving up on it cynics lose that
chance
our studies and many others give us a
clear picture of the cynicism trap
when we decide everyone's out for
themselves we stop seeing their kindness
when we think the world is zero-sum
everyone becomes a potential enemy
these views spread across us too
parents pass on their suspicions to
their kids politicians act in bad faith
and damage voters faith in each other
media companies trade in judgment and
outrage
our cynicism is their product
and it is a growth industry
so no
cynicism doesn't help us see reality
more clearly but it does change reality
poisoning our relationships our lives
and our culture
it is not a system upgrade
it's mental malware
but we don't have to accept it we can
take control of our stories to escape
the cynicism trap we have to
my lab tries to help
in one study we taught people that
happiness is not a zero-sum game and
that helping others helps us too
these folks compared to those in a
cynical condition donated more to
charity afterwards and they ended up
happier as well
in other work we changed how people
thought about empathy in politics
some people were randomly chosen to read
a cynical essay
it began and i'm paraphrasing
you might think that empathy is a
weakness that will make you lose every
argument and you'd be right
afterwards uh we asked these folks to
write a note about gun control to
someone they disagreed with and they
sniped at each other
here's a voice actor reading what one
democrat wrote to a republican
it's hard not to state this bluntly
you should be in favor of stricter gun
laws because you should care about the
lives of other people more than your
outdated feelings of machismo and here's
a republican writing to a democrat
people need to know they're able to have
the freedom to bear arms in order to
protect themselves you democrats don't
get to take that away from us
basically we recreated twitter by
accident
other people read a different essay it
began
you might think empathy is a weakness
that will make you lose every argument
and you'd be wrong
and went on to describe empathy as a
strength in politics
again we ask these folks to write to an
opponent about gun control but this time
things changed here's a democrat
there are some common sense regulations
that we should implement to keep people
safe we all want what is best for the
country and there are things we can meet
in the middle on to tackle the issue of
gun violence
and a republican
horrible crimes can be committed using
guns everything from school shootings to
murders because of racism and white
supremacy
it's very understandable that you think
it makes sense to make gun laws more
strict we're all reasonable people and
we just want what's best for our loved
ones
to us this was wild
remember just like ocean and lake
fishermen these people did not start out
any different
but just reading one essay turned some
of them into new optimists and others
into new cynics
this shaped how they acted and their
effect on other people
we sent all of these notes to people who
really disagreed with the writer about
gun control and found that notes written
by new optimists were more persuasive
than those written by new cynics more
likely to make other people change their
mind
in other words we taught these people
that empathy was useful they used it and
it became useful
this is what i want you to remember and
what i want you to know
that if cynical stories can become
self-fulfilling our work shows that
hopeful ones can as well
now cynicism is not the only root of our
problems and optimism alone will not fix
them but it's hard to change a broken
system if you think it's a mirror
reflecting our broken nature
if people are selfish to our core then
toxic laws and practices are here to
stay
but we can all choose to tell a
different story we can be skeptical
demanding evidence before we believe in
people but hopeful knowing they can
change for the better
we can notice their kindness even when
the media doesn't and envision systems
built on that kindness
we can find other people in our
neighborhoods unions and faith
communities who want the same thing
we can use our collective optimism to
build pockets of solidarity and mutual
aid miniature ocean villages that can
grow over time
now this is the part of the talk where
i'm supposed to tell you how i cured my
own cynicism but the truth is i still
struggle
depending on the day or the hour i
promise i can be as cynical as anyone
here
but i see cynicism for what it is a
psychological quicksand that will pull
me in deeper the more i move through it
so i fight to believe in people
not because it feels good but because
stories matter
and we're telling ours all the time
together
we all get stuck in quicksand sometimes
that's okay
but the next time you manage to pull
yourself out and find some faith in
humanity try to remember to reach back
and grab someone else who's stuck
until more of us can make it to solid
ground
because optimism is not a relic of the
past
it's one key to building a better future
by letting us see it more clearly
thank you